got a new job recently and I have a boss
from hell I'm pretty sure I'm going to
get fired soon the problem is I enjoy
the work and I get paid well I tried
looking for other jobs similar to this
but there is none in my area I feel like
I'm walking on eggshells at work like I
know it's a matter of time before I get
fired I paused baby step two to start
saving in case I get fired I now have
$2,200 saved up should I start one
looking for a new job to downgrade
everything except child care to prepare
for the worst case scenario so yeah it
should be looking for a job right away
uh and taking maybe one or two extra
jobs while looking if you really feel
like the shoe is about to drop and you
can get fired at any moment you just
want to be stacking cash which means
making some extra cash right now if it
were this bad the way you're describing
it um I would be working extra saving
extra pausing some things sure but let's
move quickly